i'm gonna try not to squeak my voice
here
thank you to the academy
no really thank you for uh just such an
amazing experience uh for for dan and i
and thank you to uh eric and haley for
your
just awesome films thank you to the
other filmmakers for not only being so
inspiring but for just being just
wonderful
genuinely
awesome people you've made this
experience just unforgettable
i would like to take this time to thank
my producer my co-director my friend dan
uh he brought so much experience to this
film and
if i could describe our working
relationship
uh if if life was blazing saddles
this is dan clark saw it as a rock
technical director
and this is me the creative director
thank you for for everything uh thank
you to everyone at brigham young
university who worked on this film uh
all the all-nighters
the stress thank you to the faculty
thank you to
cynthia hogan for
helping us understand the the crazy
bizarre but wonderful art of animation
even
even though she was having health
problems thank you
i would like to thank my family for
telling me all the time wesley your film
is not going to be a disaster you're
still going to have friends when it's
all said and done
and thank you to my girlfriend taylor
for your patience for understanding that
animation takes time
for sharing me with the program and for
your love and support
wesley's hard to follow
he's so sincere and he has so much heart
and emotion and that's obviously why the
film is speaking to people um and so i
have to thank wesley for being that
heart and soul of the project um because
without him our film would have been
about that flat and boring
i of course need to thank pixar for
taking the chance on me especially for
fran for sticking her neck out for me
thanks to my parents
who did so much to get me here i owe
them everything um we are remiss to not
thank jennifer lawrence uh for being
such a huge inspiration uh
thanks to caleb you know why and of
course uh most importantly to me uh
thank you to my wife uh she's everything
to me and without her i'd be nothing
thank you if there's if there's one
final thing to be said it would be a
quote from the classic film miss
congeniality where
we are all winners and we really do want
world peace thank you